This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Wow.
[inaudible]
yeah,
original.
I'm on the road this week,
dog. I'm out there doing it. Uh,
let's see if there's a chance
you can get into any show.
I think you might be able to get into
the late show this Saturday in new haven,
Connecticut.
The late show,
three 30 it might have a
few tickets left after that.
I'm hitting the road in a couple of weeks.
Going to Madison.
Late show has tickets on April 11th.
Milwaukee late show has a few tickets.
April 12th.
Uh,
Nashville maybe has a few tickets left
on April 14th from then I roll on out.
Um,
I'm in Boston in late April.
The only show with tickets is April 28th,
April 28th at the [inaudible] theater
and Medford May 1st I'm in Portland,
Oregon. You can get tickets there.
The May 2nd show is sold out.
Then I roll into Seattle for the third,
fourth and 5th of May.
And the late show on the fifth is the
only show that has tickets available. Uh,
those are all at [inaudible] dot
com slash tour I got to tell you,
if you're listening to this
show watching April 9th,
the email will go out to everybody on
my email list for tickets for the second
half of the take it down tour.
You can get that email if
you sign up on my site,
there's a prompt that comes up if you
sign up for it, you get the email,
you get access to tickets
before anybody else.
There's going to be 25 plus US cities.
Uh,
there's gonna be a whole Canadian
tour and there's even going to be an
international leg.
So sign up,
get that email and a,
that'll come out April 9th.
The general on sale will be April, I
think 10th or 11th. So good to know.
Um, what's up gene? Okay. Homies
booking. Good morning kind of fights.
It's fucking morning.
All right.
Mini apple tits. I'm coming
for Ya. April four three, I got
my eight o'clock shows sold
out on a Friday and Saturday.
Thursday tickets are still available
as our late show, so snatch those up.
They're moving really quick.
May 10th and 11th Tempe at the Tampon.
Tempe Improv. Uh, that's an Arizona.
And then May 31st through
June 1st sperm bank,
California here at [inaudible] Paris
comedy club. June 20th or 20 seconds,
Washington.
Dick come at the Dick.
Come and prob cash me outside.
How about that?
Oh my God. Oh my God. Dang me outside.
That's your fault. You play that
fucking song. Tickets are available.
Add Christina p online. Also,
if you're new to the show,
you have not seen my Netflix specials.
They have to stand up. Specials.
Mother inferior my hour and a half
minute special called the degenerates.
What I did eight months pregnant.
Pretty wild. It's so crazy. Also,
Ryder Dye tee shirts available.
That's my tour name. Ride or die
available at a Tom Neurosis March page.
Once you got an Inbox,
what? You fucking got it
right over there, homie.
We're in fucking Syria homes.
Check this out dog.
She got bro.
This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you in part by Manscape.
Oh the number one,
number one in men's below the belt.
Grooming the manscaped offers perf
precision engineered tools with the right
tool for the job. So I got two
of these. I got two of the CD.
You've got to smoothies. I got I, I took
it for a spin and I got a second one.
The uh,
this is the lawn mower 2.0 wow.
This is like the tremor that you always
wanted. You don't know. But for guys,
you know,
we're always trying to like keep it kind
of tidy and neat down there and you can
snag your nuts and really do some damage.
I mean it's not a flat, oh man. I would,
I would have a date with some floozy.
I'd be like,
I'm might clean up everything below and
then you cut and you're like, aw man.
Now there's a little nick there. There's
blood running down my leg. It's terrible.
These guys saw that.
That's actually a real pro.
Why are you going to ignore guys balls?
These guys are actually doing something
about it. Okay. The perfect package.
Two Point Oh kit.
This comes with the lawn mower
2.0 with skin safe technology.
The trimmer that won't
nick or snag your nuts.
It's also a hundred percent waterproof,
shock resistant.
These are precision tools and a for your
precision tools for your family jewels.
I love the way that think and I will
say spouse approved because I tested the
merchandise after you were done.
Never seen them.
That smooth and freshly shorn.
I know.
It's like it took 10 years off your nuts.
I'm going to make this a daily thing.
I love though. These guys don't just make
this, they got ball wipes. Oh Wow. Yeah.
Oh Wow. You're a dude. You know
you get like how much time? Nuts.
Anyways, they got all
kinds of, they got here,
they've got their own shower gels and
ball sprays and so it's a total ball kid,
dude.
It's awesome.
Get 20% off free shipping and a free
travel bag with the code mom@manscaped.com
that's the 20% off free shipping
and a free travel bag with the code
mom@manscape.com guys,
start taking care of those nuts.
Keep them healthy, fresh, clean.
You know what I mean? I do.
And I'll tell you that. Um,
oh, the ladies appreciate it.
Or whoever you're with is
going to appreciate that.
A little extra attention to that
little lugs to cleanliness, tidy,
very kissable, very touchable.
Hey, hey now just saying,
there you go, man. Escaped.
Uh, guys, I will let you guys fight over.
Who gets to this whole other kit.
I mean,
my inclination is that Josh
needs it the most, but whoever,
whoever wants it,
I got a kit for myself so I see that.
I know it's in the bathroom. I love
it. We are ready to do this show. Jane,
are you ready? I'm very ready. I
can't wait to watch this opening clip.
This is good stuff right here.
Let's do it.
Okay, so I've got a fun video
for you. This for jeans.
Good morning,
Julia.
Are you having fun or hardcore fun?
Let's go full throttle.
Try it out.
Take about 10 or 12 Benadryl.
Lots. A lot of better.
Don't do that. Chill baby. Um, so, uh,
I hope that, hope that's
what he wanted. Um, and uh,
hope it sounds like you,
you're a group of friends is super fun
and a little crazy and you got a lot of
inside jokes. Um, so sending you
lots of love. Thanks guys. Oh,
your mom's house.
Christina
Japan.
You guys,
I'm sorry I talked over if that's
okay. Awesome. A lot of Benadryl.
Let you guys heard this was so amazing.
This was sent to me and uh,
Tom and I this morning, I
forgot, I'm sorry. I forgive.
I forgive me for the person who sent it.
I didn't put it them on Twitter.
We'll figure it out.
It's a clip from cameo.
It's cameo where you get celebrities to
make videos that you pay them a certain
amount of money. And this video
came in. This is Beverley Mitchell.
Remember that show? Seventh Heaven.
Yeah, this is, I'm a potter.
Used to have a crush on her. Is that
right? Yeah. And I know that, uh, anyways,
she looks the same.
She looks great.
She plays like one of the younger kids
and something that he obviously got her.
Oh.
At Mr Dennison d Mr Underscore d.
E N. N. Y. S. O. N sent it.
Give him some love, uh, for
that one. That was crazy.
That was the best thing ever. She looks
great. She's still, she still looks nice.
Never that fucking show. Seventh Heaven.
It was like a weird Christian and yeah.
I never watched it. Neither
is lame. Yeah. I remember that
Jessica Biel was on it. Oh,
Diaz is calling. I should
probably answer right? Yeah,
go for it. Just in case. No one
dog. Hello? Yeah, he was like,
so Joey Diaz is coming over for people
listening to do the podcast and then
that, that'll be in a couple of weeks from
now. Yeah, I'd be in a couple of weeks,
but he's,
he calls me,
I sent him directions with a map on it,
like the PDF,
which shows like here's where you turn it.
It's really like explicit.
It's to give anybody who's trying
to find the place clear direction.
And he's like, so when I get off the
highway, oh, I go right. And I go,
yeah, like right. Like, so you're
going north away from the cities,
like don't start with the fucking
north and south. All right. He goes,
I'm not a fuck a boy
scout. All right man. I go,
what? I don't know what to tell you.
He's like, do I go right? I go, yeah.
And he's like, and then at the other
street, another right. And I go, yeah,
I have no idea. I'm just like,
yeah. And he's like, and then what?
Then left at the other thing and I go,
I'll just be out in the street.
Does have a gps. Come on,
who are you talking now?
He won't even accept text
message. He's like, tell you why.
If I've been drinking the shit, my ass was
going to be on file. I can't wait. Yeah.
Oh good. We got them Fart Mc for, I don't
know if you want to give that to him.
I don't know if you want to
start that. I do. I actually,
you know what we haven't had
against, yeah, you're setting,
you're sitting pretty close.
Just a reminder.
I'm used to Joey's farts and he's
like my kid at this holy shit.
Anyways, uh, we, we lost track
here. So this is Beverley
Mitchell. Um, I was saying,
I remember Jessica Biel,
she cause that's what she got famous on
and everybody was enamored with Jessica
w worse. So, um, but then this
cameo things kind of, it's,
it's an APP. If you guys
don't know it's an APP, right.
And all kinds of people have
signed like are doing it where you,
you can pay them to send a measures
and they have different tiers.
So like there's Instagram people and
then there's TV and then like Farve,
you know,
Hall of fame.
Superbowl winning quarterback is uncanny
and I think you have to pay him 500
bucks just to be like happy
birthday. Yeah, exactly.
There. Jim, your friend
Bob, he lucky you love,
he said her tail bone ready.
Uh,
wranglers are good pants. There's
another thing. Don't forget about that.
Go go packers. I just, I don't know.
I feel like if I was going to start
making, I just do it for free for fans.
You know what I mean? Well,
I mean, you know, I'm not,
I'm not hating on the whatever.
Yeah. I don't want to do it,
but I think it's fine that people do it,
but I really liked the people are
hitting up people and having them do your
mom's house stuff. That's
hilarious. That's a good investment.
You know what's so
funny is seventh heaven.
That was like a blatantly
Christian value show. It was. Yeah.
I think the far right,
the father was like a priest on the show.
It was like a minister and I think they're
like, oh, you used to watch the show.
Really? Wow. Scandalous happen on bill's.
Really the only thing I remember, I
mean, is that why you watched? Yeah.
And you're like, God, let me marry you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. And like she, you know,
she seemed cutting young on that show.
It was like, oh, that's kind of I work.
Do you remember when I worked as a
site rep? We were married, so it was,
it was less than 10 years ago.
I worked as an adult man,
I don't know if I ever told you, but
there was a guy, so as a site rep,
you would go to a building that they're
shooting a movie or production in and
you just represent basically the building
so that the production doesn't just
destroy it because they will don't
give a fuck. And you'd be like, Hey,
this is a Christina's house.
I'm just here to make sure.
And then they'll start like nail and shit.
So you had to kind of protect it.
And one of the other site reps,
it's guy was like 26
27 was legit obsessed.
Obsessed with Jessica Biel
boy. And he was like, yeah, my,
I have pictures of her all over
my room and oh boy. He's like,
I know I'm going to marry her one day.
And at first, like if someone said,
you're like, ha ha, yeah. And then he
was like, no, for real. When I was like,
you're gonna Marry Jessica Biel? And he's
like, yeah. He's like, well, he's like,
we're meant to be together.
And I was like, fuck,
this dude is seriously delusional.
And I would bring it up like
I wouldn't see him for a week.
I'd see him at the office.
I was like, Hey Jessica,
plans coming up.
And he would be like,
oh no, I know you make fun of me for
that. But was he a gang banger to know?
He was kind of about though. He had
like someone bought the blood, he was,
he was from Ventura and he likes to serve.
He was like,
where it's like we're like a perfect
match, you know, like it's a delusion.
Get the level of delusion
that it wasn't like,
it's one thing if you see like a
teenager like that stu was a grown man.
I used to think that Ricky Schroeder and
I would fall in love and get married to,
what were you like 31 silver spoon?
He was my first love.
My first crush was Ricky Schroder. Yeah,
I mean he was well off. Good looking.
Yeah. I mean I hadn't, I had that
crush on Alyssa Milano course.
And then what was the blonde,
the beautiful blonde on the other,
the one that Scott Bayeux finger.
Yes. Yeah. Yes. Her Nicole,
Nicole Agricor. Oh, call Acre. Used to,
I used to think if you learn their names,
there was a good chance you
didn't have together. Right.
Cause I was an advanced level for a
kid, for a kid. And you're like, oh,
I read the credits and I
know this person's name
calls with me. And I used to,
I used to buy like those
big bopper magazines,
remember those stupid
magazines for like teen girls.
And then Ricky Schroder
would be all over it.
And I have like the poster on my wall.
It's just loved him.
And then it became Johnny Depp when
21 jump street came out. Oh my God.
21 jump street. Johnny Depp. It's so
cute. Yeah, he's still looks great though.
Yeah. For total look great. I know. Crazy.
He was wild to dude. I
know. I wish she would, uh,
hit the craziest thing. Is that a article
about him? The, the spending article,
he's like, he's like really has, um,
like diagnosed, you know, spending
impulsive. Yeah, yeah, sure, sure.
He's like, buy 30 of those. Okay.
The craziest thing to me still
is that he smokes in his house.
Rolling cigarettes. Guy Spends 30 million
a month. I'm like, yeah, it's Kinda crazy.
And then he's like smoking cigarettes
and sound like this guy's fucking nuts
right now. I wish you would come on our
show, but our show is invitation only.
It's was invite only show. Yeah, you gotta
be invited. You can't just come on here,
but unless you want to,
you want to issue an invitation.
Why don't you go ahead and look into your,
are you agreeing?
I'm agreeing Johnny Depp to be
on our, yeah. Yeah. Johnny Depp.
If you're listening to your mom's house,
you're watching this on youtube,
you're invited to come on as a guest.
I extend the invitation to you.
You're welcome. That's very
nice. You, yeah. Oh, speaking
of Nice things. Guess what,
what? Um, I dunno if you guys
don't know if you even know.
Do you know that I'm hard rock.
Nick was on tosh 0.0, oh yeah.
And we got a shout out and they
played footage from our show.
That's pretty solid. Cool. I'm a little
upset because they only mentioned Tom.
They're like, and Tom Segura is podcasts.
I'm like, what am I chopped liver?
What about Christina p two
Netflix specials. Hello?
What am I fucking that just the dumb
girl. Well, the gator, you know,
like on radio and that like the, you know,
you're, you're Rick dees and who am I?
Yeah, no, I understand that. The sidekick
check just some dumb blonde girl. Well,
yes, I think that, I think cocreated
your mom's how were cocreators?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm very offended. I'm
actually very upset. The Daniel Tosh,
I'm offended. Josh says in radio that that
role is called the whole on the whole,
Oh, the Gash. The girl, I dunno.
Wall. That's terrible. Josh.
Giggle. Gash. Did we come up with a
proper name? Chocolate fucker. Yeah,
his was giggle. Giggle. Gosh,
he's out of his fucking to be fair to de
to Taj though. I actually know him. Yes.
So do I. No, no, no. I've talked
to him backstage before. Yes.
Now I fucking know down. I know. I
know. Nick Wagner. That's his guys. No,
that's not who worked for him. That's
a different, it has different guy guys.
I'm 10 years behind. Yeah.
Catch me outside. Cat know.
I've toured with Danielle though.
That's right. I forgot. Yeah. But still,
it's fucking disrespect.
There's just some blonde chick there.
Just some fucking dumb bitch and then a
cool jacket. But anyway. Unbelievable.
What the level of disrespect aside
from that little hole. Disrespect.
The segment was very funny. It
wasn't very flattering. And they did,
they gave a shout out to they,
yeah, they did say cite my name,
but they played a clip from
our show, correct? Yep.
The two of us talking about hard rock the
whole time and hard Rudnick to in his,
uh, defense was, um, was game
and was very fun on this.
I have to give him credit. He, he
reacted differently than I would.
I would maybe at the expected
from somebody so attractive
and so muscular and so
wealthy. I would think that
somebody like hard rock,
nick wouldn't even give them the media at
the time of day. Yeah. He's a busy dude.
He's very busy.
I thought he was hilarious too,
that he has not broken
on his claims so on.
I saw him on a rider
and then they're like,
and you really are worth like 100
million. He's like, he's like, Yep.
Doesn't he doesn't bend at all in
any of those claims. Pretty Fun.
That's been at least having a good time.
I think he's having a good time and he's
on cameo by the way. It hard, right? Yeah.
I'll plug it. Okay. Shit. Okay.
Go check out. I don't know
what he's charging though.
I know. I wonder guy that rich shouldn't
be charging him. He's a millionaire.
He could be doing this for free. Yeah, I
know some other people do. Kathy Griffin,
she does thumb.
Yeah.
Lance Bass approached me and I said,
dad, no thanks. Yeah, it's not, you know,
but I don't know. It's not for
me. I personally, like I said,
if I wanted to do videos for fans,
I just fucking do it for free.
I give shout outs to people on their
birthdays and happy birthday to,
yeah, we should start doing birthday
shout outs like on the radio, you know,
like that's fucking dumb. Whose
birthday's today? Nothing.
I hate more than a happy birthday.
Fucking I get emails all the time.
We'll be at your show on Friday.
And uh,
my friend Cynthia, her, we
give her a shout out also.
She, uh, she's got big ear lobes.
If you want something to make fun
of her about like, yeah, I know.
I can't wait to stop my
show brought to do that.
It's my adult friends birthday.
The
only thing is that crazy to me.
Like you're an adult.
No one compares more insane than
like we'll be at your show sometimes.
It's like, it was a group of us
coming. Uh, ted is guys crazy.
If you want to fuck with him, you know
he's always got a truck. You never,
it's all dirty and shit. He never,
if you want to make fun of them,
Ted here, why don't you wash
your truck? Everyone was like,
that's hilarious.
So fucking stupid.
No are my favorite is I get
people emailing me, hey to,
hey Tom's doing a show in Fort Lauderdale.
Can you ask him to help me get proposed?
No. That's the one that I
hate the most. And by the way,
just so you know how unoriginal you are,
it is every week,
every week I get multiple emails.
We're going to be at the show Saturday
and I wanted to do something really
special,
like what I want to propose
to my girl at your show,
hoping that maybe you
could bring me up on stage.
What do you realize how little
everyone at that show cares?
Nobody want you getting
engaged and nobody, no, I just,
I had to stop myself from writing back.
How much I hate them when they email
me that, but well, it brings the worst.
Also brings the comedy fun
to all of, yeah, let's stop.
Let's stop the entertainment.
Let's make this show that
has 1800 2,500 people at it.
Let's make everybody stop
and watch you go Alyssa.
You know,
you mean the world to me.
You're a girl and he's all
nervous and shaky and then,
and then he has the story of,
remember we were at that show,
everyone hated us for stopping the show.
So I could propose to you remember,
am I going to say the club?
But they would. They would. I
had it happen twice. And clubs.
I've had it happen several times.
Yes.
But then the owner wants you to plug
the blowjob shots. Oh yeah, yeah.
Before you're set. Yeah.
Does Dallas Fort Worth yet?
It's so stupid.
Just go ahead and plug these blowjob
shots and then just go worse.
That's the one where the guy goes,
you're the only guy that's
ever said anything about this.
He told me I was the only guy
that's ever, I was like, okay,
all right man. Yeah, no, I had, um, I
had proposals. Here's what I had though.
So the first time I ever had it happen,
I was working at club and they were like,
some like they basically informed me,
they were like,
someone's going to propose
that. I was like, okay.
It was as bad as you can imagine.
Guys all nervous and like people
and then people are getting,
when I realized how much everybody
hated it by the next time it happened,
they had to ask me.
They're like,
do you mind if somebody proposes during
the show? And I go, I absolutely do mind.
And they were like, hmm, what
can we do? And I was like,
you can wait until I'm done with my show
and I go, you can do it after the show.
And that was the compromise.
I was like,
once I'm off stage and back in
the green room, I don't care.
You can have the guy take a shit on
stage and people are filing out. Yeah.
So that's what they did
finish with their Nachos.
I've had people ask me to
marry them a lot and um,
I'm not going to do it just cause
I don't, you don't want me. Yeah.
I mean I appreciate the, no, the
offers. Nice. That offers. Nice to say.
Would you like to be the
efficient of my wedding?
The offer is insulting and selfish to say.
Do you mind if I propose during your show?
Because it's just so you know.
You're fucking rude. Okay.
Oh my God. You're selfish.
Your balls are freshly shorn,
but they're back down.
You need to get your Dick Mount tonight.
No one wants to snapping
already had started.
Can propose price testosterone
running through you right now.
No, you're right, and again, I don't,
I appreciate the offer to
officiate your wedding, but I,
I'm not the right candidate.
That's different. That is
different. That's saying,
would you like to come to this thing?
It's an invitation like this podcast.
It's invitation only. That's absolutely
right. It's the same thing. Not just any.
A whole can come on here and you can just
send me a fucking thing, you know? Hey,
why can I be, no, no, no.
Of course we have to Ordain you
worthy of being on our show right now.
Who is he getting text
message from sexting?
Can we try it out your beard and trying
to fuck and I knew that would upset you
know that man.
So in that ever since I've been going
like real short with with a haircut and
everything,
I have to do this horrible maintenance
of getting it clipped all the time
because it starts to look shitty.
Would it has any growth on it?
Like getting haircuts like every two weeks
when the beard is a little wily look.
Well I like it a little look dirty.
I like, but you don't understand.
That was my attraction to you is that
you look dirty and gross and homeless.
I like it.
Don't you get that?
I've always loved that about you.
That you're just nasty, stinky bear.
I like it. Oh Harry and
stuff. I love your soul.
Have whiskers for an image
of myself. Yeah, of course.
But I like it when you're a little
unkempt. It's masculine. All right,
well I just meant that like, so here,
obviously in the front it's thinned out.
So when you have thin hair in your front
of your head and you're doing the buzz
cut, you got to keep it short.
Otherwise when it gets any growth,
it just highlights how thinned out
it is. You know what I mean? Sure.
So it started to get there and I was like,
I seem to go and get it cleaned up.
I keep calling these two places
to do it because they're near us.
One of them is always packed and I
never remembered to call ahead of time.
I always called day of, we'll call it like
nine in the morning. And they're like,
we're completely packed at him.
Like Jesus Christ.
How many people are getting their damn
haircut? I Dunno, they, they're like,
you want to come and wait
and I'm gonna go. No.
So I called the second place and there
was a lady who did a pretty good job.
Of course she's not there.
So I go in yesterday and I tell the dude
what I want and I mean it's not totally
fucked up, but he fucked your beard.
He fucked my beard up. I'm not,
you're the one that said that when you
came. I know, I know. Just so you know.
The funny thing is I gave him like,
I give them all a nice, I'm nice,
but I go with them like really explicit
instructions and he was like, yeah,
I get it man. And he did it and I
was like, that's not what I wanted.
But the good news is you're,
it grows fast. It does.
So in a week it'll be normal again.
He cut the line, he took it up.
Here's what's wrong, is that he cut
like he gave you the dad line like your,
your beard grows. It's got to go
further down here and the chin.
I know he's not American.
Oh, he was of course not
unexplained was he did, he did.
He was sitting microwave
is curry fucking morning.
I had my coffee yet.
Fuck, fucking morning says
that fucking morning. Yeah,
that's what I want. That's how I
would want a boss to talk to me.
Me Til you get to work. And
he's like, it's fucking morning
now. It's time enough with the
business. We're going to get into it.
We had the great pleasure,
the joy,
the benefit, the wonderful
time to have Sean Evans here.
So delightful and invited him on the
show. Yeah. And he was like, yeah,
just like hot ones. You know,
Sean is the host of hot ones,
the wildly popular online show,
a youtube show,
a that first we feast.
It was on the last season.
Um, yeah, it's a, it's a,
it's a big show and Sean is
like just the sweetest guy,
I think the best host and
interviewer in the game.
He's absolutely my favorite person
that's ever interviewed me and I love
watching him hosts that show.
If you've never watched hot ones,
you can do a deep dive on that.
It's so fun.
They might Shaquille O'Neal episode.
Yeah, we just watched that one. Um,
he has usually has, you know,
a mix of like athletes, actors,
rappers and comics. Always plugging
a comic and every APP every season.
Um, and it's great. And so I'm
thrilled that he came here.
We had the best time with them.
We played our own game with him so
we played wet ones with them. So, uh,
hope you enjoy it. Here
is Sean Evans. Everybody.
Hey,
what's going on everyone for why?
Mh I'm Thomson [inaudible]
and you're watching wet ones.
The show would land water
and even blend or questions.
Our guest today is Sean Evans.
John,
you are the CEO, chairman, host
president and director of,
what's it called?
Hot one's hot ones. Yeah,
that's another show. Anyways,
that show is much better. So first
up we're going to give you, um,
this is a shit water for shit.
People that don't know any better.
Go ahead and crack it open.
All right.
I won't even taste mine cause I
think it tastes like dog shit. Yeah.
You know that tastes like, what
does it taste like? Hold on. Jam.
Like it's disgusting trash.
Do you have like a,
do you ever have a hose attached
to your house? Yeah, yeah.
I used to do that and pull that move.
Yeah. Now it does taste like hose water.
I agree. Sean, what's your favorite color?
I was actually thinking about this the
other day cause I think I just wear
creams and grays and blacks all the time,
but I feel like those are boring colors.
It's like I'm happy that orange exists.
Do you ever, do you wear it though?
No, cause it looks horrible on me,
but orange I think is my favorite color.
I can create it though.
You at the point now where then you start
to appreciate somebody who will wear
colors. You know what I
mean? Like bold. Yeah.
Sometimes I'll see somebody and like an
orange or like a a real blue that pops.
I'm like, Yo, I wish I could be you. I'm
not. It's aspirational. It's aspiration.
I won't do it. Yeah, we
won't get there. Next up
is aquaponics,
this natural spring water.
You know the difference between that
bullshit Disani in this minerals. Oh yeah.
You can taste the minerals
for real. Yeah. No, I,
if I would reach for this when I'm wanting
to quench my thirst and then it's an
exotic drink.
But if somebody offered you this bottle
of pis or this this a hundred times,
I'm going to put this,
I think we should square them off.
I'm going to put this to the my right.
That means a preferable place. Shawn,
did you ever think in a million years
that you would be doing what you're doing
now? No. I mean we didn't
even think that, uh, you know,
we didn't even have that high hopes
of for the show. Like just in general,
what do you think it was a one off or no,
no,
I thought that we could make this quick
fire Internet side show, you know,
like celebrities coming in, burning their
face off. I thought, you know, even,
I didn't know if necessarily it would
have a host or that you'd see the host or
that it would play that role in it.
Originally,
our idea for it was it for to be this
like swinging light interrogation show
where we'd just be like interrogating
the celebrity and forcing chicken wings
down their throat and they'd just be
like fighting through these questions and
the wings maybe by themselves.
Like, maybe I don't even eat.
And it was Tony [inaudible] from g unit
who helped us workshop the show and he
was kind of like,
you know,
no self respecting famous person's gonna
come in here and just choked down wings
while you pepper them with questions.
Like if you want this to work,
I think you have to eat the wings too.
And it was really like the best and that
was like unintentional that that worked
out like yeah.
But it clicked for us.
Like I remember the light bulb going
off or like, oh yeah, I like that.
Makes a lot more sense. And then hot ones
was born. Dude, it's an amazing show.
Thank you to the amazing shape.
And the best part about it 100% is you
because you are a gifted broadcast or an
interviewer. I don't know how
you'd do it. I really don't.
I think part of it is that you actually,
it seems like you take genuine
interest in your subjects,
which is like what you realize
if when you watch, you know,
a talk show or radio interview,
especially at like,
we're always the subject of
interviews, you know, where you go in.
And like a lot of times with
radio there'll be like a,
they're just reading like,
like a bio line. They'll be like, you
went to University of San Francisco,
Wikipedia and you're like, this is
the second line in my bio and says,
here you did Netflix special.
What was that like?
But yours like yours or are way,
way more researched in depth.
It feels like you actually
take an interest. Well,
I think that it's such
a competitive space.
Like the interview
space is so competitive.
So if it's like you're going
to get eyeballs, you know,
and you're going to compete for those,
then I think your show has to
be that exceptionally good.
And then I think the other thing that's
played into that as the audience,
so many people are
cult-like with hot ones.
They're hot ones fans and they're just,
they're there every single time.
So you feel like you have to impress
them every single time. So it's like,
let me respect your audience. I, you
know what I am, I'm scared of him.
I'm scared of that audience.
I'm scared of them.
I think they put such pressure
ones. Have a Fart Mike. No,
but we need one.
This is a fun one.
You should have a farm or
a show needed a fart Mike.
Wow.
Giving you permission to take the idea
because I thought you'd cornered and if
we, by the way, if you please, if
you have to Fart, I'm grabbing. I'm,
I've got you. Thanks. Gotcha.
The only thing you know,
you never know. You know, you always
have to be ready. It could at any,
although as a, as a, an alum
of hot ones, I got to tell you,
when you're in, when you're in
that room and you feel a Fart,
you're not sure what's behind it.
Oh yeah, I know. It feels like,
it feels like this might
be a shit Mike real soon.
Cause I remember asking after
you did hot ones, I'm like,
how was your Brown after? And it was,
I took my, uh, I'll tell you this,
you can pass this advice on to future
hot ones who are hesitant to go forward
with the game,
so to speak.
When I worked at Chibo
on sunset many years ago,
which I think is still around the
all Mexican and Guatemalan staff,
they would make crazy hot
dishes all the time for us,
everything was like super spicy and
a lot of us, you know, would be like,
man that looks spicy as it's
going to kill me on the way out.
And they were like most
of what you gotta do man,
you get bread and you
butter up that bread.
Heavy butter lines the track.
Like if you know you're going eat
spices and that would completely,
and now a lot of times when you go out
for something spicy, you weren't in,
let's say planning on it. So you're
ruined. But whenever we did that,
when we ate the buttered like thick
buttered bread, it like, I dunno.
So did you do that before hot ones
though? No, of course not. I'm not smart.
I'm saying I remember
that. Yeah. But you know,
it's weird that I come across somebody
on the other side of hot ones,
but I always do ask them like one, what
was like the next couple of days like,
and then do people come up to
you in the wild and they're like,
oh no, cause yeah, I mean the,
yeah, I mean fish. I remember, okay,
go in and do hot ones. As it got closer
and like it was really first we did,
first of all, we did the, um, the
burger thing, which we'll get into it,
but when we did the hot ones,
I definitely had some apprehension
and I was like, I was like, oh man.
Like how bad is it? So then you
start, you know, you're watching them,
then you get distracted
by how good the show is.
You forget that there is going it.
But then like day of or day before,
I remember I called Bert because he
had done, yeah, yeah. And I was like,
I was like, I mean, what's going to happen
here? He's like, it's hot. It's very hot,
but he was like, it won't be that
bad. Just so fun. And if it hurts,
just let it hurt. That's what he told me.
He, that's good advice. Yeah, it was good.
He was like, just like, he's like, you'll
recover. And I was like, all right.
And then I still remember being there,
like, I dunno it, it kind of feels like,
you know,
there's a parachute in a way,
but you're still like a
little worked up about it.
And then the thing was that for me,
from my personal experience,
I was like four or five weeks in like,
this isn't bad at all.
But then there was that
the bomb. Yeah. Yeah.
And that was worse than what I had
imagined it could be. Right? Yeah.
That wrecked me. Yeah.
There's no period for that.
But then it's funny because when
I watched, when I watched it,
and I'm just watching it as let's say,
try and take myself out of it as content.
I go, this is like one of the funniest
parts, watching someone's struggle,
sweat. Can I actually remember
that? I couldn't remember.
You would ask me a couple of times.
It gets loud.
You feel like that a speaker feedback
situation or something? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I was like, ah man, I don't know where
to go with this right now. All right man.
Just stop ruining my shot.
Next water. No, go to Fiji.
Just jump ahead to Fiji. Yeah,
this is dog shit too. Yeah,
we just put the dog shit out
there to remind them that
they make dogs your water.
But this one, oh this is garbage. This is
that. They put that all over the place.
Like I feel if you're like
getting her high g model chick,
you product place with Ascensia.
Yes.
That's very specific and
accurate. Yeah. Yeah.
They have like a real
online marketing strategy.
I feel like that one we learned that the
Ph stuff is nonsense. Bullshit. Yeah.
Martin Risa is a American is Waterstone,
Yay.
Of German descent. Of course. Um,
but Martin taught us a lot and
one of the things you've told us,
you know how when you Fiji
there's like a silkiness to it on
your roof. Like, that's the mineral,
I think it's called Silica.
Silica or you could feel it.
Yeah,
it's smooth. That's minerals, man.
That's silica and that is delicious.
And that leads us to our next question.
Fedex or ups,
Fedex or ups.
Fedex, you know, like not,
I've been next day and some stuff
lately and every time I hit the FedEx,
I feel like in New York you hit a
FedEx like every third or fourth door.
Yeah. So it's just in that, you
know, I mean ups, I'm always like,
are we fucking really doing this right
now? I agree. It's such a third world. No,
I don't think it's, I don't know
if I've every been funding into a,
Fedex has the u s on lock,
but then you go international maybe with
ups or what's the DHL? They do that.
Like DHL ships on the Zimbabwe.
You better do it to DHL.
Fedex is really got it down here.
Yeah. Yeah. I don't fuck with ups. No.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
All right.
Are we moving on
is real bullshit,
but it's crap.
The reason I bring it up is
that it's brilliant marketing.
It's probably in the running for the dog,
shittiest of the dog shit waters.
And we learned a lot about
this from Martin as well.
It's like triple distilled,
which means it's stripped of all
minerals. So again, it's like,
you know, I don't know. He might
as well drink pool water. Right.
Do you like straws?
Well, you know straws. I feel like there's
a lot of bad PR with straws right now.
I feel like I'm a bad
person if I use a straw.
But then at the same time I wouldn't,
you know,
like the metal Straw situation and the
substitute, like who has time for that?
Those you do? I do at the house, yeah.
But then I have veneer so I'm always
afraid they're going to chip arm or
claiming. Yeah. But then do you have
to like think ahead and plan, you know,
like a straw, so impulsive, like there's
just a million straws on the counter.
You just grab the Straub when
you're drinking something.
Yeah, I have him in the,
in the cupboard, bunch washed, ready
to go. Yeah. And I just pawn down,
put it in my smoothie, whatever. See,
I know I'd have a hard time doing that.
But then at the same time Strawser good
because I feel like I have bad teeth.
Like I feel on a genetic level really.
Parents handed down bad TC that smile.
How are they bad? No, I think I'm like,
but I think I'm just like a on a cavity
level. Like I feel like I get 'em
they're just, they're softer and
weaker than most people's teeth,
but a straw it'll help, you know, cause
like if you're drinking something straw,
it'll bypass the teeth. You know,
you don't take on that contact.
Do you use Sensodyne sensitive?
Not just a straight crest three d,
You know,
I'm very be stripping your
teeth even more. Really.
I would argue you should switch to a
sensitive tooth paste like
a Sensodyne. Well, I'm sold.
Yeah, no, that's dope. Shit.
I feel like your Straw wise,
I feel like there's some type of like,
so you know how like basically
a few months ago there
was like the real big push
back on the straws and you started,
they started to like,
we're going to take straws
away. Starbucks. Uh, I
went into the one of these,
so I go every day to one. And
one of them was like, oh yeah,
there's probably not gonna be Straw as
soon. So now they're doing, uh, for,
for ice drinks, for cold
drinks, a lid with an open.
And I was like, well, I just
go like, well, this is just
the new reality, you know,
I just like, this is what it is. Like
we're all becoming children. I mean, I,
and I just kind of was annoyed, but I was
like, you know what, I, it's not that bad.
And then the next week they're like,
not a straws again. I was like,
what happened? And I was like,
people must have been like, fuck you.
I'm not not using a straw. Right. Just
it went away like immediately. Yeah.
I Dunno. They were basically
announced that, no, you're a child.
And then people were like,
no, I'm not. Okay. Well,
I like when the people when it back.
Yeah. You know. All right. Christina,
what water you want to go
through a straw, I guess? Well.
I'm a huge fan of Avion.
I would argue with all these waters
and this is the highest quality.
I like the taste. I will pay the extra
money in the airport. It's a drink.
Also a specific taste if you really, I
feel like we grew up on it. Really? Yeah.
You grew up on this. Wow.
Damn. A lot of money.
I didn't grow up on this shit.
Okay. Offset. We'll call him on.
You're talking about dog town hot ones.
I feel like it's a good water but water
champ or are you going to bark this one
down? Excuse me? Are you referring
to him as a minor? My bad.
You saw the eye contact. Wow.
Looking when he said that. Wow,
and guess what? Guess what? We
have a new water champ bottle.
It's in the store now.
Go to emerge method.com/thompson garage
and look up the new water champ bottle
where you can pretend to be
the water champ in your house.
Just like she pretends to him. Pretend
water champion. Watch the footage.
Watch every episode of this show. I'm
constantly drinking more water. Your town
might smell sad.
What does she say
about that now?
Do you feel like here you
are this good looking guy,
you're making money,
you're getting famous,
more famous everyday you're in this
relationship. How dumb does that for you?
But I don't know. I feel like
I'm, I'm playing up in that.
I feel like if you,
if you pulled a hundred people
and you showed a picture of,
of me and,
and go ahead and put all the stats,
go ahead and put the resume there
and then you throw one up of her.
I bet 96 out of 100 are going to say
he's lucky to be with her or not.
She's lucky to be,
yeah,
I bet it would be like in the nineties
the nineties your lady, what's going
on?
Who is Shama Fram Onoway and know what
our first date was actually at your guys'
show.
Yeah,
the store let the end of
the commedia and yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay. And she's
a fan actually. You know what?
She likes the, she likes the eighties mom
bit. No, a lot of people do. Right now.
I'm going to have to expand on that.
It's cool. So what's her story?
What does she until uh, she does
like this sort of thing to not, um,
not comedy podcasting,
but she does like OnAir hosting red
carpets and so she's very pretty,
she's got to be stunning to
do that kind of stuff. Yeah.
She was like a Laker girl.
Miss California. See now
you now you will end jeans.
Really not, you'd walk it back though, you
know a town, you know. Hold on, hold on.
I want to look up. I'm sorry
about what I said. Laker girl.
So she saw a Lotta these, I'm
assuming. I don't know. I don't know,
but allowed to. I don't think so.
I think that, I think that, uh,
are you reading about the cheerleading
and stuff that's coming out? You know,
I feel like it's, it's such a tough
job. Like they don't get paid.
They have to pay their own.
Uber's out to like whatever our home,
they have to go shake hands
ad or whatever. You know,
I think it's a tough gig being a
cheerleader. And then I think, yeah,
if you like talk to somebody on the team,
you're, you're, you're out of there. Wow.
I think it's like that.
That's crazy
to a Laker game. And, and this is not too
long. It was like a couple months ago.
And first of all,
this is somebody who together
15 years basically, right? Yeah.
Sports, zero interest, no games.
Like never. She's like, oh,
you're watching a game. Just walks
away. I take her to the Laker game.
She's got a pool of drool on her shirt.
Her mouth is open and she's like,
she's like, she's licking her lips and
then we get in the car. She's like,
I really liked his Laker games. And I
was like, Oh yeah. She was like all the,
and they're so big and strong and you
can see everything and the shorts.
And I was like, okay. And we couldn't
see enough. And the shorts, yeah,
yeah,
yeah. That was, you want to tell
him what happened that night.
Oh, and then so then she
was like, anyways, the next
Laker game you can set up,
that'd be great. And I'm like, okay,
I'll keep it in mind that that's your
new favorite activity next morning.
She's like, guess what? I had a dream
about. I was like, what? She goes,
I dreamt that I was with you,
but instead of you having what you have,
you had a big black cock. And I'm
like, whoa. But he had a big black dog.
Yeah, it was cool. She was like,
okay, so how long have you been
with this lady? So, I dunno.
I think that show would have been like,
I don't know,
like 10 months ago or something. Yeah.
That was really your first date. Yeah.
And I remember he was texting me, you're
like, oh, it's sold out. No, I know.
But that's,
but that was,
I think he made me look cool because
then you put my name on the list and then
do the comedy store's credit. They're
very old school that way, you know,
they're very, like, these
are toms guests, you know?
And then like three people come down
from the ceiling and they're like, oh,
let me show you your seat. You know?
So it's nice. You know, like they're,
they're very, uh, they're very cool that
way. And then we, uh, went backstage.
Okay.
Member. Yeah. Yeah.
We went backstage and we chatted for
a little bit and then Hannibal rolled
through with Thundercat. Yeah.
It was a good, it was a good,
I was just telling him dire state.
I've been like, yeah, you looked super
slender cats album on repeat. That
was what you asked me yesterday. Yeah.
What is it? Because you've been on a loop
for, I dunno how long. I'm such an idiot.
Oh, sorry. I was just saying that like,
I've been listening to that album
on a loop for a year and a half.
And then when I met thunder cat, I had
no idea who he was. I was like, hey man,
and then I just walk out of here.
It's true that southern famous
singer were in there, beautiful girl.
And Hannibal was with them.
And I was like,
what do you guys do like for musicians?
And I was like super famous. Oh No,
you are. Yeah. No, that's a, that was par
for the course. Yeah, sure. Yeah. Okay.
That's cool. Yeah. Just coming
full circle married. Yeah.
How it'd be pop the question stuff.
Jesus.
Why don't you fucking lay off
a little bit? I love it. I
can't wait. Hot seat. Yeah.
Yeah man.
All this shit away from my face.
How many seasons are we into a
hot ones now? Eight. Eight season.
Eight finishing in a couple of months.
150 episodes.
Can you announce anybody that's coming up
or no. Is that like top secret? I don't,
I don't really care. The only thing is
like, fans get sold like Wah Blah, blah,
blah, like when they're like
looking for a, their episode. Um,
but I don't really care.
I think so this week we're
dropping Billie Eilish next week.
Shack.
Hmm.
Wow, man. That's got a big one.
That's where I live with Shawn.
Can you imagine?
Imagine that though on Tom's body.
I know what dreams are made of when,
when?
Funny question to ask you that.
Okay, fine. Any questions?
Yeah.
And the
Theo van after that. Yeah. And then
we shot one with Chelsea
handler. Oh, good. There you
go. It was good. It was fun.
I like. Um, I liked it by the way that you
keep the comics in the game. Thank you.
Bad. Like you've had the, you have the big
movie stars and then you have athletes,
rappers.
But I love as comics.
I love that you keep comics in the loop
and I think that's just good for a show
to just cranking the cops,
you know, like people,
I think sometimes people want like a very
specific kind of viewer experience all
the time.
But I think that that's what makes it
good as when it's like this sort of island
of misfit toys,
you kind of know what expect but at the
same time don't know to expect a week
over week thing.
So thank you for saying that because we
take a lot of pride in that. Absolutely.
Yeah. And then we booked
like a big finale today.
I'll keep that hush for now
and then and then and then we,
and then the show is, so I did, I did.
That's a good one. Yeah. And then,
and then we'll take like a couple of
weeks off. I was fair to you after,
I guess the NFP and then,
um,
and then we'll take just a couple of weeks
off and do it again. You know, it's on,
it's on fire, you know. Thank you.
I appreciate that. And there's a,
you guys are actually, you have
hot sauce out there. What's game?
Yeah, yeah. I show.
Can I bring you a gift?
Yes. Oh my gosh. That's awesome.
We use hot sauce. Oh, snails,
plastic hot sauce. Got The classic. Bam.
What else we got here?
We got the lowest Kelly and just
the way
he would have been. Oh,
last DAB that, you know,
this makes you go caca and your pumps.
The last Dab. I love it. Yes. Twila pain.
When you do the show, that's what you
throw on the last week. You want to die,
go for it. And then you'd
do it. So it's here. My,
it's funny to watch. I think that's the
best part is watching people react to,
that's half the find is like,
oh my God.
And it's watching famous people hurt is
pretty funny, right? Because I think too,
uh, it's, that's the
most common man thing,
like celebrity is inherently
this unobtainable thing.
And it's like everyone's always
trying to make these like,
what's it like to have a beer
with them shows, you know,
but like really the most common
man thing is dying on hot sauce.
It's like something that's like,
nobody knows and it's like the only legal
way to like physically harm someone.
It's, it's such a great
concept and it is like this,
it's relatable in a weird way, right?
Yeah, exactly. Like you're like,
I know what it's like to eat something
spicy and then to see the different
levels of suffering is like
amusing and entertaining too.
And that's been such a, an
education for me because, um,
now that I'm thrown into this world,
it's not like I was some hot sauce guy
or chili pepper guy before all this
happened. But it is crazy. The
range people have, you know,
some people can eat a curry and it's fine.
It's just chill.
They might as well be eating cereal and
then some people like one bite and they
completely start to melt down. You know,
so that's even interest tolerances.
It's incredible all over the place. Yeah.
People really, some of them, you know,
if you, if your life is spent eating
certain foods, it's like you can't yeah,
you can get there. Yeah. You can't
even scare them. Right. And even now,
like having done this so frequently,
like now I can, you know,
the tolerance is definitely gone up.
Are you sure?
You know when I was in Korea
I would go eat in the more
authentic, you said Korea,
Korea. I would train myself.
I would order Soondubu in there,
hot as soups and I would just blow it out.
I get like diarrhea every day and then
by the time I came back to the states,
did you see me eat? I should. All
the time Korean food came cheating.
I would say 2012 but I
don't get diarrhea anymore.
You can really train yourself.
Your biology completely flips.
How has this work going to ask? Doctor
drew this question? You don't know him.
It starts with a B last
name with a k because it be
alcohol, drink, drink, drink,
drink, drink. Nothing happens. He's fine.
He can drive one of the most
racist Faddis you've heard of him?
[inaudible] hot wings though.
Is that it is a, it's sadistic.
When you want to hurt
yourself or masochistic.
I always forget how to say
it as to which one anyways.
It's self punishment going into it.
Is it masochism when you hurt your
baby and I love him. I know anything,
I don't know.
But it's like you looked like you'd know
you're really into that stuff but you
order it just to punish herself.
You know it's like the most,
it's the most bizarre
meal and I do it a lot.
Like I eat them a lot in airports and
stuff. Do you like working on planes?
I'm like,
why am I doing this?
I throw a hot sauce sometimes when I
don't want hot sauce because it's offered,
I order a lie, a lot of eggs and
on the road and they're like,
you want a hot sauce? And in my mind
I'm like that really? I'd be like, Yup.
And then I don't know.
And then like sometimes I'll be like,
that's not enough hot sauce and bottle
and drown it. And then I'll be like,
this is going to hurt. And then I
eat them like off, everything hurts.
Now my stomach hurts.
Do you ever catch a buzz off
it in a weird way, right?
It's like a high catch, a little high.
Sometimes. I like it to hurt my mouth.
If it's sour too. I love sour.
I'm like, oh fucking burns.
I love to,
I hit you up about this stuff.
I love studying the
business of, of, you know,
we do like entertain, I love the
numbers on the phone and I, you know,
as soon as you owe that Gordon
Ramsay, uh, episode, uh,
blew up. Yeah. You know,
I was hitting you up like you believe
this shit cause I was excited for,
you know, it's crazy too
because, uh, you know,
from the time that we put up the first
episode with Gordon Rate or without
Gordon Ramsay first episode ever,
everyone's like,
Gordon Ramsay has gotta get on the show.
He got to have Gordon Ramsey on the show.
And then like,
that pressure was so loud all the time.
Like every tweet,
people would respond to it as like,
when's Gordon Ramsey on the show
and my ige comments, like whatever.
So there was so much pressure that like
forced us both in the room together and
then you feel like you have
these ridiculous expectations
for it. But we're like,
all right, well we'll just going to throw
the kitchen sink at them. Just try to,
um, you know, just make this just
the most outrageous experience.
Then he went to Bristol farms
and like picked up all that stuff
that he was like using like the lemon
and lime juice. Did donuts. Yeah.
And he's just like fighting
off the spice that way.
He was really aggressive with it.
And we'll, the Brits, the Brits are,
they have like a real aversion.
Their palates very bland.
Every person from the UK that we've
ever had on the show has always been
struggle city. Yeah. Cause I run
Russell brand funny to see him.
I mean it was like doughnut bite
every, like the sweet, you know,
it came from an educated place to, as
a, as a highly trained to showman level.
I A showman level. Um, but the other
thing that's fascinating is like,
obviously I know he's super
famous, you know, like, you know,
he's a well known person, but to see
that response to that degree is like,
I got excited just seeing
that response mean to like,
we'd never had anything that crazy,
you know,
like we knew we'd drop it and it
would do well. Like we knew that,
but the way that people just took
with like the way people took off,
I don't know, probably like 30 million
or something. Isn't that fascinating?
That's crazy, man. It's wild. It's great.
Good for you. Yeah. So crazy. That
is crazy, man. That is, that's nuts.
Um, eh. Oh, do you wish
you were taller? Yeah,
I think like if I think about
things I'd change about myself,
adding two or three inches would probably
be in the top five. Yeah. I would love,
I think I would take six to and just be
like, how tall are you? Are you six foot?
Yeah. I'm like right at it, you know?
But I feel like six two would be like,
you know,
you're like one of these
guys who's like six, eight,
you just like a fucking monster
walking around and you don't want that.
Especially if you can't
ball then you'll know.
Then it's like your hand is way over
there. Like how would you even control?
I've got one. Okay. Would you rather
be taller or have your peanut B Baker?
What's up with how dissatisfied are,
I'm just asking.
It's just rather
your answer for me.
I'm just thinking because I was just
thinking women don't want to be taller.
Generally. I don't want to
be tolerant guy. Absolutely.
I wish I had a smaller boobs,
but I could buy that.
What would you want from me?
What would you want from me? For,
for you? For me? Yeah. Perfect.
I don't want anything that's called
a wife John. I wouldn't want,
why would you want taller or a bigger
pener taller. I feel like I feel good.
I'm like a Dick level. I feel good.
Like I feel like I just have like,
like one you draw.
Like I feel like it's very like,
like what they'd sell in the
store, you know? It's very,
it's like factory standard and I
feel good about it. And then a,
it's nice,
but then yeah,
I would like to get taller.
What do you want?
Would you like to have like hair,
like surfer dude hair?
You know what? I don't have, I
don't if I would either. I don't
know. Like, like people are
like, oh, you know, you're like,
we have a similar thing going on.
Right? Yeah. And You keep it close.
It doesn't bother me in the least same.
And I kinda like it the way that
I cut through the air, you know,
the way I feel the breeze, you
know, it's, it doesn't perspective.
I actually liked the way it looks. I
don't think I'm in the dance. I'm good.
I mean if somebody told me like,
Hey, would you rather be like,
like her perfect physique or taller,
that's one where I'd be like,
perfect physical. I'd take perfect
physical cause he can, I can I, you know,
I made it this far. I don't,
I don't obsess about the
height. Whatever. Who can I,
I'm sorry.
Were you going to say no,
I was just going to say
I wish I had awesome.
Do you wish I had like another
couple inches down here
in a movie?
So little more growth credit.
Kind of like the water bottle
where you're like, okay,
okay, I got this from a movie
I get. Again, I can't take
credit for it. Would you,
would you trade five years of your life?
You lose five years of your life to be
in perfect shape to have like a model's
body.
Even hesitate on that five off the end.
Um,
I'm not going to tell you which
five could be five prime years.
I'm going to take five prime years.
How does this work?
They've just go into a coma or whatever
and then you can like take away 30,
you go to sleep at 30, you wake
up 35 and that's, that's a coma.
Sure I'd take it, but your body's
Rad. Like you, you look perfect.
There your whole life. I think
I'd take that. Take those
years gone. Yeah. Fuck it.
Yeah.
Now check out right now.
Where do I sign it and then I'll
just come back and you're like,
the boys are in school.
They're doing well.
Your children's lives just for the first
five years, nothing important happening.
I'll come back to like, who are you?
I'm like, your dad, who was Lebron?
And I'm like,
oh my God. Yeah. Okay.
What about you? Yeah.
You check out. Yeah. I don't give
a shit. If someone were to be like,
now because of my children,
like if you go back to being like 30
to 35 fuck those years. Yeah. Take Em.
Fuck those years, those years you've got
married. Don't care. Don't care. But I,
you know, when you come to the realization
like I just have in your brain,
you always have the hope that one
day you'll have a perfect body.
I'm going to work out and
I'm going to look perfect.
It's never going to happen for me. But
you finally, are you there, right? Yeah.
Like I had that realization this
morning. I was like, oh, this is,
this is all racked today.
But you had the realization that this
is as good as it's gonna get. This is,
this is it. I had two children.
The, this has ravaged, this is gone.
You feel like it's all downhill from here?
Absolutely.
I mean I'm going to maintain and do plot
these twice a week and I'm going to eat
well, it's not going to get
great. It's what I'm saying.
I'm never going to look like a model.
Yeah. You know what I mean? I kind of
do you still hold a delusion that you're
going to be how you look when you were
20? Yeah, sometimes. Yeah. I think I get,
I think I do. Yeah. And then what
will happen is like, you know,
you have like a couple of good
or decent naked days, like yeah,
you go to the show,
especially if it's like, uh,
worked out like three days in a row.
Yeah. And I just came from listening.
So if the muscles are a little swollen,
like just like blood in them and you're
like, you know, this is pretty good.
And then maybe like a, you have a day
off and then the next day you're like,
how did my body go to shit in a day?
You feel like,
I mean it must be obviously
all in your head, but like
I'll feel like, oh no, it's,
it's back to shit again.
But maybe it makes it kind
of lazy sometimes I feel
like it does that where I'm
like, Oh, well I could snap this back
in at any time, so fuck it. You know,
now I feel like I'm, I'm pretty far
from it being even decent, you know.
No, no, it's good. That's good. That's
nice. You're a nice guy. I mean, no baby.
You are. You're beautiful. Beautiful to
me. Thanks man. You're a handsome man.
Appreciate it. I'm on, I'm in movies.
You are, you're in perfect. I love him.
I just booked another mood.
It's not a PT now. All my parts,
by the way, in the last I just
booked apart. I did three last year.
The parts were like
obnoxious brother-in-law,
a corrupt city councilman.
Yes.
Corrupt police officer and
coming up, uh, corrupt.
Uh,
or like asshole tech guy.
The family one with Mark Walton.
That's, that's good. He's just tall.
It's got a good rotten tomatoes though
town that does it pretty well. Right?
But I've told you this, that you're
going to flourish as an asshole.
You're character is asshole.
My style. You're good at it.
But that's what he's good at. Camino.
Yeah. She goes, you know what your key is?
You know the way you've said it
to me? She goes, you know what?
You're really going to really do well
in and I'll be like, what? She goes,
you're a fucking scumbag. You
scumbag. She's like, you're a, well,
she knows he's a shows casting.
Yeah. Aesthetic like, you know,
you don't know how you look.
You look like a scumbag.
Homeless, degenerate. You married this.
I love it. Well, why do you
think, who are my types? Yeah,
she likes Benicia and
I'll tell you what I mean.
So what's the guy with his dick in
the girl's mouth? Vincent Gallo. Ah,
I like crazy homeless, looking
smelly. Lifterlms all catcher.
I'll catch her at a stoplight
looking at a homeless,
kind of licks her lips a little bit.
I'm like, oh, stop. It was like, oh,
he needs a hand stop. No, his legs. Sean,
do you ever play this game when you're
on an airplane and people are filing
passed you? Um, when you see a woman,
do you go like, that could be I,
I think I could love her.
And then you find something
immediately wrong with her or like,
could that be my spouse? And
then you go, no, I'm because
she's got like her hair is
parted poorly or three toe rings.
Yeah.
I think I am like a people watcher foyer
at heart and sometimes I find myself
staring at someone and then trying to
think about what it would be like to walk
a mile in their shoes or something.
Yeah.
I start to like wonder what
they're like or how, you know,
if I see somebody walking by carrying
bags of stuff, I'm like, you know,
how did they end up in this position in
their life where they're carrying those
bags on this street and stuff.
And then I find myself thinking about it,
I think a little bit more
than your average person,
your average walker by would,
you know? Yeah. But I don't
do that specifically in the
plane. I'm not like, oh,
I could marry that person. Then trying
to find something to disqualify that.
Oh that's pristine. And saying, that's
my game. I think I could love me.
I can never love you.
And then I'll find a superficial reason.
Do you find yourself going a rooting for
who's going to sit next to you and all
these all the time and praying.
It's not that person,
but it's always that person
that smelling next year.
So I've got to ask you this
because it seemed like,
I actually think you have the best
gig going in entertainment. You know,
it's like such an awesome job and the
show keeps getting better and the,
you know, they get, it's like, it
feels like it's a perfect gig. Right.
You know,
and a lot of ways it is everything that
I always wanted and it's a small team,
you know? And every time
I talked to somebody else
who's doing some other thing,
I popped the hood on it and I realize
like I'm happy that I'm in my lane doing
my thing and nine that lane doing
that thing all the time. Uh,
it's labor intensive.
Obviously we travel so much.
There's so much research built into it.
Uh,
the postproduction in the show plus like
the frequency with which we like crank
these things out,
which the edit is like the key one of
the most amazing components. Thank you.
Yeah,
I appreciate it.
We worked so hard on that because I
kinda just want everyone watching it to
really feel that pain in those moments.
You know,
like I always think like the evolution
of it is some imax experience where like
they spit out the water and you get like
sprayed with water or something. Like,
I always think like it could be bigger
than that. Some sort of like oculus rift,
you know,
a experiential thing is like when I look
into the future and think about what
the show could be or whatever.
Um, but there is the wings,
there is constantly eating death wings,
you know, it given a take. Yeah. Okay.
That's the part I get.
But I feel like
most too, like the part
where I go, you know,
there's gotta be either it's floated
to you or it's in your own mind like,
well then you know the TV show, the
talk show, right. It's a natural,
you'd be a total obviously natural host
at it. Thank you. But then you go like,
you know, and you know, maybe
there's a time and a place for that,
but I feel like every time like for us
will, you know, be like, oh, you know,
you need to be doing TV and more,
you know,
stuff that like traditional shows
closer, you are around it. You're like,
oh, there's so much shit
you have to deal with.
And then we come here and we're like,
oh,
we get to do whatever we want,
bring out stupid water bottles and the
crazy club, no one tells us anything.
That's the thing,
kind of the great gig and I think too
is we've made this team like as we've
conquered every single
day added to this team.
So now I love everybody that's
around me and yeah, creatively,
there's nobody who's going to get
them my way about anything. You know,
like I could die on any hill that I want
to and I feel supported by the people
that are on the team and I'm really proud
of the show and what we do and the way
that it's just sort of done laps and laps
and laps around everyone's expectation
and then just completely changes
your whole perspective on everything.
So all of those ways, like, you know,
you kind of want to soak
in this moment and uh,
stay on track with it and maybe even try
to help that train go higher and faster.
Uh, but yeah, I think about that all
the time because people, you know,
like whatever, my agent or like whoever,
they'll always be like, oh, what's next?
What's next? What's
next? You know? Or like,
that's just people and that's like nature.
And I'm like,
I kinda just wanna this is tightened my
grip. Yeah. And just this thing right now,
especially if you've got a successful
thing, ride the fuck out of me. I know,
but don't you feel like people
are always like, well yes, let's
do I want to rip all the cords out and
try to put it into something else and
then try to get this whole thing
back? Like, yeah, fuck no, no.
It's the silliest thing. If you find
lightening in a bottle, which he,
you clearly have and people want to
watch it, just keep doing it right.
And people show up. So I'm like,
what do I want to fuck? Yeah,
but love the people fucking that Mia fund
that people like our fanatics for hot
ones and, and people like, you know,
I've experienced the people coming
up to me just from being on hot once.
It's like, you know, and they'll
quote lines from it and yeah,
yeah I get emails about it and you
know people and the they love that.
They love that.
Like I brought up trick daddy cause then
they're like you not only were guests
but you clearly had been watching the
show and that trick daddy episode is like
a super debt to me is the
most underrated episode ever.
It's not like this coin amz
like tens of millions of views,
but it's arguably like one of our
best interviews and check daddy.
What I love about it is when
he first got there, he wasn't,
he didn't know what hot ones was looking
at it like how are we rolling like
that.
But then you kind of see his shoulders
drop and he just falls into the show so
effortlessly.
And then we're having this like deep
dive career spanning interview on Trick
Daddy. And he started to
rock with it in that way.
And then that acid in part that
you referenced is one of the,
one of the moments we're most proud of at
the show. Barn away, eat a Buddha gang,
eat a booty gang life.
You seem like a pretty together person.
Do Your parents support
your career? Yeah, uh,
my job with the gifts he's given them now.
It was a good Christmas
for my dad. But yeah, like
they've always been super supportive.
My mom passed away when
I was in high school,
but my dad super supportive even like
coming out to New York cause at first it's
like hard to explain even uh,
you know,
he's not watching youtube and stuff
so he's like, oh you're going to do,
you make a web talk show on
the Internet and you know,
like the exactly a little bit like okay.
But he was super supportive and then,
you know, once we got people like
Ricky Gervais' and the chair,
once I did cold bear,
like that was a big deal for him because
he was such a huge Letterman fan.
So like that being in the same
theater and the Ed Sullivan Theater,
that was like, it was like, oh
okay. Like bear to play your game.
I know that was,
you know when he spit milk on the stage
of the Ed Sullivan Theater. I was like,
that was such the, it's such a
top of Mount Kilimanjaro from me,
you know? That's awesome man. Now you're
originally from Chicago? Yes. We love,
we were big fans of accent.
Chicargo. Have you noticed my drawl?
You all like your professional
broadcasters? So smart.
Did you go to a good college? I went to
a pretty good college. Where'd you go?
University of Illinois. Yeah,
but you couldn't see ivy. Oh,
we were just studying on the wire.
They get top dollar.
I do. What did you study? Wait, Brian
Broadcast. Broadcast Journalism.
Have they had you come back yet?
Well, I want to go back and yeah,
they've kind of hinted at it and I get
like tagged and like the school's Twitter
and stuff and then kids that work at
the newspaper. It's a buzzing thing.
Same with like at my high school.
Well,
what I think is weird is that I grew up
in a northwest suburb of Chicago and I
see that the like local newspaper there,
they've never said a damn word about me.
You know, like they, I
don't know, maybe, you know,
like the hometown has never been like,
it's never even acknowledged it.
But um, whatever. Like I'd love to
go back to University of Illinois.
I think it's like, uh,
cause that would be cool.
I think that if I were a student
there now and I watched the show,
I think that that would be so cool. Yeah.
Like I think Hugh Hefner went there.
Some good broadcast is I went to
u of a Roger Ebert and me will,
the accent is like the,
when someone has a hardcore act,
like all types of were just
fascinated by it. Yeah. Yeah.
But one thing that's really
interesting is if somebody,
I don't know if you've ever heard,
let's say somebody with a hardcore
Chicago accent who's actually really well
educated.
It's a pretty amazing juxtaposition.
So check out this guy speaking and just,
you know,
just give us your thoughts
reserve on Duis. San Joaquin
Delta. It's a, it's pretty amazing.
It's nice to see too much of willows.
You get their mesh of coast live oak
growing on the shore as much invasive
blackberry brambles.
And despite the,
the metastatic tumor of modern society,
there's still a couple endangered
place which haven't been knocked out.
I mean, this guy really knows tumor
and he's kind of philosophical work.
It's not just about the plant life,
right? Yeah. Um, it's like that.
You remember that Snl,
Chris Farley, uh, like the
bears go bears dot bulls.
He met Jordan 242 the rest of the guys.
Six six.
Yeah.
It wouldn't be antioxidants.
Primrose and there's just supposed
to be a wallflower are risks,
some of which is in a Brassica family
brand stick of fame. We might've,
I think it might have bloomed already.
Dude,
I've never heard anything
smart come out of that accent.
Do you think he knows he's funny or do
you think he's just a second? I'm like,
this guy thinks he's Farley in
the sketch and then I'm like, no,
I think this guy really just
knows this shit. And he's,
he's one of these guys who's fascinated
by something. No one else's, you know,
like he's really laying out what plants
are out there with enthusiasm I think is
genuine, which makes it smart guy. The
towns down with the accent. Yeah, exactly.
But like I love when somebody is
enthusiastic about something that was just
fucking plants. He's like,
hold on a second, let me
give you the fucking details.
He'll persuade you. Like know I'm
into it a little bit more. Right.
When you guys play these clips,
do the people in the clips ever
acknowledge sometimes guests
ever reach? Yeah, like either that's
so funny or stop doing it sometimes.
Like always a lot of people who you're
like, look at this fucking shit show.
They're like, can I come
on? And they're like, no.
And then the people who you're like,
I wish we could figure out this is,
you never ever hear from the lens of
our desperate like king ass rapper.
I don't know if you're
familiar with his work.
He's a gentleman that farts
on food and eats the food,
which we could find that guy. He's
another one. Like the elusive. Yeah,
I mean it's another celebrity.
We'll never know. We've,
we've, believe me, we've
tried to find this guy.
Not a chance king atrip where we
actually do have him on the podcast.
I feel like that would be to
try something. Try that guy.
I would be the move.
Yeah. I would send a car.
I've put them in the trunk
of the car. I'd be like, yes,
please come talk to some.
He beat me.
I don't really hire security
for that day though.
The guys out front I don't think. Yeah,
no, no. I think I'll try it out guy.
We'd need to be like, Hey, can
we have an armed officer here?
Cause I don't know where
this is going to go,
but I would really love to get to
the bottom of that video. Yeah,
that's my favorite video of us. That's an
interview on the you guys could do too.
Now. Uncle Pete, uncle
Terry would come on now.
I don't know if we could have one.
We couldn't really,
couldn't we have more than you think?
I don't know man.
I know we can't even plays clip
anymore. We should probably, yeah,
actually. Right. If, uh,
like if he's talking and he's
not shoving stuff up is asked,
then I don't see us getting
flagged for that. But
I mean we've lost so much money
because of that guy already.
Yeah, that's true. Yeah. He's
really fucked us. But um,
yeah, basically we're not allowed to
play for people that are wondering,
cause we had to cut him out of a
couple things. It's because, uh,
people are the video.
People were like,
you can't have that guy
putting stuff in his ass.
Yeah.
That's how you lose the Mcdonald's.
You're really out there listening
is gracious. Yeah. He, um,
Terry really forced drug gang.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh. He's a ride or die. This right here.
Oh, Nasdaq. So that's, that's
Terry having an orgasm.
It's super slow. Mo. We're
allowed to, I found that we're
allowed to so nasty. Yeah.
Now is your girl, is she
cool? Is she in a farm board?
She's, uh, she's chill. She's
cool. She do foreign, not I, I,
I'm trying to keep the romance
alive as long as I can.
I'll keep hearing this from,
this is modern though. What
is this? Tom has no idea.
That's pretty good. Now, did you fart
in front of other girlfriends now?
He's not fine.
He's no gentleman here town.
How long before you started
just freely? 14. No, it was
a three week. No, no, no, no,
no. It wasn't. It was a
few months because I was,
I remember the first time it was a,
I would,
I would spend the night at
your place. I was, you know,
next morning watching TV in your
boxer shorts. It was a weak one.
It was a few months. It was a few
months, but what I did was to,
to break the fart barrier. I went,
I did, instead of being like,
here's a little Fart, I just decided to
go for it. I didn't think about it. Yeah.
But I took her hand.
I put it between my legs and have Fargo
on her hand for the first part and she
goes, smells like garbage, smells
like garbage. And then I was like,
well at least we're getting there now.
I think that if you're going to do it,
that's probably the way to do it I think.
So to wake somebody up with
just the bucket full ice water,
like that's exactly what happened.
What did you think about that afterwards?
I never really know. It's another
red flag that I chose to ignore
your, so, uh, you know, it was dad
in the serial killer talk early on.
It was a red flag and I was like,
I don't know.
There's so many good things about yeah,
yeah, yeah. Um, I just pushed past it.
I just liked yet, you know,
Tom, I'm so attracted to him.
It's like this just thing,
this, this unconscious thing. I can't
control it. No matter what he does.
If he farts out, he could shit on my chest
and I would just be like I ear to ear.
I would just adore him, feel, come on.
I would adore you. That's really sweet.
And you can do sweet. Besides cheat on
me, I would fucking cut your painter off.
But other than that,
she meant that I'm meaning.
That's like the only thing you could
do. What counselors cheating? Oh my God.
I don't know. Have, I mean we have our,
I have my tour bus permission. You're bang
blast privileges. I'm allowed to like,
I know you told him, make it, throw
it around on the bus. Oh my God.
I never told you that. Oh Shit. Alright.
And condoms are a must.
I always wear a condom.
Okay. And then, you know. Right.
So what did your dad do growing up?
Are you, were you, are you fancy?
Did you grow up fancy? No. Uh, he's
a judge. So like you grew up fancies
smart and fancy. I'm not
fat. I didn't grow up fancy.
It didn't feel that he has a
federal judge. He's like a,
he works for the Human Rights
Commission. So, uh, you know,
civil rights cases, she's smart as
hell. He is smart. He's smart as fuck.
Yeah. Wow. He is super smart. He's
like, did you do the wing guy? Huh?
But that's fine.
Me and he was never, you know. Yeah.
But yeah, but I mean now and yeah,
but now I think,
but that's,
it's like kind of crazy about youtube
in the world and stuff is cause now when
guy makes more than the,
the judge for sure now are
their expectations for you
to go to law school and
follow in his footsteps. And I don't
even think that he'd want that.
He didn't really put, you know, I didn't,
I didn't have that kind of pressure on
me. I was like, Eh, you know, if anything,
because he worked so much. And then
so I feel like I was like almost head.
Are latchkey childhood a little
bit more. I was very lucky. Yeah.
It was very like $40 by the phone
sort of childhood, you know,
like that sort of situation,
garage door combination
go sort of childhood.
And how old are you if I may I
euphoria 32 Jesus, where you're young.
I shouldn't even be a latch key kid, but
I thought you were 50 you're not 40 yet.
Okay.
But that's great because
that's really the, I mean,
look gen x or is traditionally we
were latch key kids and you know,
we created the fucking Internet and now
you guys are creating cool content on
the Internet and taking it to the
next level. That's so great. Yeah.
I want to do the dad thing where he
like, dude, without getting into it,
do you do the finances where you
tell him when he was like, well
a little yeah, a little bit, a little
bit, a little bit without getting he's,
he's more,
he's the it side of that that he shows
is more of like he's proud of me and you
know,
he,
it is good to have somebody whose opinion
you can trust when it comes to stuff
like that, you know, because whatever
people will tell it. Yeah, exactly.
So I actually like that my dad will be,
he'll come from a place of just trying
to help me, you know, of course. And uh,
he would be like excited.
Like if I moved to La and I
had to get a car or something,
like he would be excited
to go car shopping with me
because he's like a car guy,
so he could, you know,
like live vicariously
or something like that. Be An experience.
I'd be like, I'd like to show him,
you know. That'd be cool. Yeah.
I hope you do do that. I know,
I hope when you move into Leo, I think
within the year, oh that's great. Yeah.
This time, you know, cause
whatever the show, uh, the
way that it runs is on these,
you know,
12 episode seasons and these three months
on one month off sort of production
schedule.
So I'd be able to finish season 10 by
the end of this calendar year and then I
could make like a nice clean break with
everything. And then just whatever,
either repurpose or either
relocate the shot here,
which isn't that big a deal because it's
basically just an editor would have to,
we didn't have to like take our editor
who's already a California kid and bring
them to Kelly. And then, uh,
and that would be kind of all that
we'd need to do to make that happen.
So I think like January,
2020, I'll be in Los Angeles,
not in New York.
Hey Sunshine.
And now in your body,
hey,
have you seen gene?
This clip is from one of the documentaries
that I've been watching do full
volume.
Yeah.
And there are two types of personality
features that you have a great deal of.
The first items called antisocial
personality disorder. Yeah.
Nearly as someone who does
not have a conscience,
does not have remorse,
does not feel a sense of guilt
is impulse of
the typical things we see before age
15 and people who are in that label are
cruelty toward animals,
cruelty toward people.
[inaudible]
yeah, I think you're acting
range. You could widen the scope.
You could play a psychopath,
serial killer,
cool wall.
Easy.
And then the kids making these memes
are getting borderline too good at them.
I know you realize where
technology is going next. Like
you saw that guy. Oh good.
The one you see the one where
like he had like Rogan the bikini.
It was on my Instagram, Z, Christine
and p if he want to see it.
That was it looked spot.
I mean,
that didn't even look like anything,
but you know, like, like it,
it really happened. I couldn't see
the seams, you know? Yeah. It was.
And this was a Jenna Sunday.
Thank you Jenna.
She's done a bunch of these by the way.
Somebody on Twitter posted
one and they're like, Hey,
Christina is this Hawaiian road rules?
And it was a girl in the shower.
There's hits. And I was like, oh my God,
is that me? That's what I thought too.
I was like, Oh man, I'm a jack off
to this old footage of my wife.
Oh,
it's not me. I know, but
duff, no, it wasn't you at first.
I started such a savage.
I didn't check off,
but I did think it was you at first. And
I started writing to, but I was like,
those aren't my tits. Yeah. But
she had like your expression,
your shoulders and you know,
ah, here we go. Here we go.
And I was reaching down and
then I didn't. Jesus. Well,
I'm flattered that you still want to jerk
it to me. Yeah, I do. Sweet of you. Bed,
do it all the time. Really. Sure. It's not
even the truth, but they're sweet to say.
So. Oh well homie on out
homie on Ya. Yeah. Yeah.
Comedy content collective.
A person that creates that.
That's where they all get together. The
uh, all those great meme makers. I'm like,
they do all that network.
They,
so they created like this comedy content
collective where like there's like, oh,
dcis and Jenna and oh my gosh.
They all put their stuff together
tomorrow. Yeah. Yeah. So it's great.
Without them,
there's no silliness names.
They do all the Photoshop songs,
you know, just hilarious stuff, man.
Um, so what, uh, what's
coming up next man?
Just a finishing out the season. Then
I'll take a little vacay and then, uh,
yeah. Tell us, talk about it. And
you don't want I want to do, no,
not that I want to. Well, I always feel
like I have to go back to Chicago. Um,
say what's up to the family and you
know what I want to hit this year.
Have you guys been to Yosemite?
No, I want to hit a national park.
I want to see a bear in the wild.
That's cool. This is my new move.
So this is my new move for this vacay.
You're gonna take your lady?
Yeah. Yeah. That's cool. Oh, give
her pose to her at Yosemite. Yeah,
I'm getting a jet.
I'll give you a discount on the charter
if you're looking at you. Okay. Yeah.
All right, cool. Yeah.
Cool. That's a pretty, uh,
exciting trip. How long, how
long are you going to go for?
Well, cause I only have like 12
days or something, so whatever.
Maybe I can sneak a day on each side,
stretch it to two weeks pop. And uh,
you know,
Chicago for five days at
Yosemite for like a long weekend.
And then right back to wolfen down
chicken wings. And what do you do for fun?
What's your advice? Um, well I
think now I just work so much,
but I find myself when I'm in La in that,
in that West Hollywood vibe
where there's that, you know,
there's the comedy store,
you may have been in dudes when you said
that was really even after the whole,
all right girlfriend that you know
know shit. That's weird. You can ask.
But there's that uh,
there's that um,
hotel triangle there and like Andaz like
I'm a big fan of that pool on the roof.
Yeah. Popping into the pods. Margarita,
you know, some chips and salsa.
That's such a vibe up there. But then
like the summer scene at the Mondrian,
I liked that whole, I liked that
a, I like that pool scene. Yeah.
And then there's some hot ones fans
that like work out there by the pool but
they're like, like pool
towel, grunt sorta.
But that's like that's the best
connection. That's the best thing.
Cause they make that whole thing run
beyond like those a day beds or whatever
that are like have like a $4,000
a drink, drink minimum, you know,
that are usually reserved for like
whoever is in there popping bottles.
I'll just be like eating Nachos on those
things, you know. Yeah. That's awesome.
Those are the bets.
A good vibe.
The working class person that like
listens to this show is my favorite to run
into,
you know,
like say the dude who's driving
the FedEx truck or you know,
sometimes they even like, you know,
drive by and you could say, you know,
it's like the Orkin man,
the guy cutting grass and like they,
it's my favorite shout out to get you
one time I was at the pharmacy getting my
prescription found Christina. I go, yeah,
he goes, I'm listening to you right now.
And he was stocking drinks at the
pharmacy and I was like, this is crazy.
They, whenever we do a show
and uh, or like whatever,
if I'm speaking at some thing,
it's like the people that work backstage
that have the ear pieces and they're
like pushing carts or like
making food or stop or something.
Those guys are always hot ones fans and
it's like the biggest point of pride for
the show. Like for the people who make
it like we love, we love that scene.
Plus those are the people that can make
it happen for you. You absolutely. Yeah,
it was absolutely. Then um, Sean,
thank you so much for coming today.
Thanks for having me here.
The best we can hope continued success
with the show and I'm hope to see you
again soon man. All right, thanks guys.
Ron La. Basically these
have been the sandwiches,
balls,
some barbecue,
all God Damn Day
10 times
from the Honda's black. Well, Daca,
Daca,
I don't
stab you in your sleep. Get your ass
out. My face. Suspect my pregnancy.
I don't feel I get what I need to eat
less siphon gas when you're outside,
you ain't shit. I pissed as shit
where I want it bad enough for good.
That kind of Danielle and they
would stop giving me so many gifts.
So they got to pay up.
You could get kidnapped,
uh, yeah. Or New Code.
You can not despair
getting math what it is,
motherfucker black and just get shit done.
Toin flows
from the Honda's
from the hunters
play around.
I didn't live outside for three years.
I lived outside cost stepping up the game.
When the fuck are we going
back to the dog park people,
chihuahuas finger Labradors,
the Oh God damn date.